[Musique]
et moi vincent qu'est-ce qui fait ton
papa c'est quoi faire du cinéma
bon film quelqu'un avec une caméra hélas
le film qui fait en ce moment devant cet
appel n'est pas un mouton enragé
tel est leur réaction par rapport à vous
en tant que comédienne je m'en rends pas
bien compte et vincent 6 août à la
télévision qui m'ont vu
et j'ai un souvenir très très amusant de
la première fois qu'il m'a vu à la
télévision on repassait le farceur de
philippe de broca et c'était blottie
contre moi et regarder fixement la
télévision et de temps en temps il se
retourner pour voir si j'étais bien là
ils prenaient comme ça et regarder puis
il comprenait pas très bien le
dédoublement
je crois que ça l'est pas de tabou
[Musique]
et quand tu es dans la maison tu préfère
penser que ta maman et sur l'écran de
télévision bien que des tac au tac toit
dans la chambre où quelques mois de la
nation
quelle est la réaction de l'enfant quand
elle vous voir alors je crois que
qu'elle trouve ça tellement normal que
ça l'ennuie ça l'ennuie je crois je
crois qu'elle s'en fout complètement
bien calé en êtes vous dans l'outragé à
un juge ou une fille allait commencement
du film une 1 un but qui tombe amoureuse
de jean louis et après lui la son chemin
à faire
de plus et plus haut et moi j'ai poussé
monsieur riche mais à la fin on se
retrouve et jean louis joue avec tous
les autres filles quand il devient plus
riche il à lomé schnyder dans une langue
superbe et flowlines de burqa n'est
s'acidifient chic et est ce que vous
prévoyez votre rôle de mère ou votre
rôle de comédienne de deux mères de
famille
comédienne moi je trouve que j'ai du bol
parce que je peux faire les deux alors
j'aime pas choisir
alors si je peux faire les deux je me
dis merde je fais b2 pipeau mais tu peux
pas faire d y avoir non non non
mais si comme tout à l'heure oui oui à
temps
c'est une fanatique pour aller battant
et ça marche bien les deux d'être les
tubes
oui il ya eu deux filles deux filles oui
je la change était jamais sans les
enfants j'adore l'état défenseur alors
je peux pas m'empêcher donc on peut dire
d'une birkin c'est une vie réussie vous
demandez à les enfants jean louis
trintignant
le mouton enragé c'est vous oui vous
voyez là la fin la grille - rage et des
bus trajet et dans lequel sombre emploi
et jane birkin
on suit le même chemin c'est à dire que
on part de peu de choses pour arriver à
pas grand-chose mais enfin une réussite
sociale
mais c'est pas grand chose finalement et
à la fin
on retourne comme au début regarder
passer les présenterai de femmes dans le
site
oui fait que ça
[Musique]